ladies and gentlemen make some [__]
noise sing along if you know the words
this is Hans Kim
this is
[Music]
DK DK will be the first comedian on the
bucket one more time for Hans Kim
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys
it's good to see you guys out there even
though there's a serial killer loose
right now in Austin
he's going after the men which is scary
because we all know men some of us are
men
not an easy time to be a man you know
all these women out here Carefree
running around
only worried about normal rape and
murder
I'm worried about a serial killer
I could be on Netflix in three years
[Laughter]
not an easy time to be a man that's why
I started a booze cruise on ladybird
Lake to save all the drowning victims
I got guns weed alcohol anything a man
could want on that boat
so far we've saved negative three lives
I'll be going on a bit of a killing
spree
yeah it's gonna be in a
being up here all right that capped me
out right when you ran out of material
look at that saved by the cat our sweet
sweet our very own Hans Kim how are you
Hans I'm amazing Tony a very good 60
seconds consistent laughs throughout not
easy to get a show like this started
high expectations everybody's been
watching your ups and downs in life we
know that you went from broke to rich to
heavily addicted to cocaine trying to
get it together he's riding the wave of
Fame selling out shows all around the
world how do you feel Huns I feel great
I just sold out four shows in Seattle
and uh thank you
you look great really the way your
muscles just
are you the serial killer no no
[Music]
I I like the way your body uh fits your
head
thank you you do you have a good shape
everything is shapely on you yeah thank
you
yeah you used to give your own haircuts
right you used to have like shaved hair
and now it's long and nice they're
growing your hair yeah thank you thank
you
uh the hair Report with Brian redband
very good uh Ian you've seen Hans many
times before what do you think about
Hans Kim uh I was about to set his pants
or his glasses
let's go one by one here uh uh the
glasses work
like I think I can see you better
through your glasses than you can see
and it's true normally when people put
glasses on their eyes get like bigger
you know what I mean Hans puts them on
you know he always looks like he's in
round 11 of a boxing match
cut me Mick
thank you Tony
can you see things good do you think
that affects driving let's just say that
there was a stereotype where
let's just say there was a stereotype
where uh Happy Asian Heritage Month
Everybody by the way
I know what an Asian Heritage a month is
it's May uh do you think that might be
part of the reason why that stereotype
exists I didn't write it but it exists I
mean it can't help
you really can't what are the odds that
the race is known for bad driving kind
of has their eyes kind of more closely
right I like how you're trying to get
recanceled a week before your
anniversary okay why don't you just wait
till next week I know I know it is weird
it is a tricky time I also have a
massive theater tour announcement coming
tomorrow it's all like it all makes too
much sense and that might be the
stereotype that's why my everyone says
agents are bad drivers because they have
small eyes I think that's a part of it I
think it goes deeper than that tell us
what tell us your theory I think we are
just okay not being good at something
thank you
[Applause]
through and through
anything else we should get updated
about it what else happened in your
personal life this week hanzi I threw up
in my hotel room on my bed
explain to us how that happened were you
drinking I was uh heavily dosed on
marijuana from the club owner in Seattle
it was a lot it was like 150 milligrams
oh it was an edible yeah
and I threw up and I missed my flight
but luckily I'm a fabulously wealthy
thanks to you guys
so I just bought another plane ticket
and yep you're goddamn right
absolutely [__] lutely you did
um I went to a tree house
my friend from high school has a tree
house it's really sick
wow he's in high school
very fun so what did you do in the tree
house I was mostly sick because I was
high on marijuana this was the same
night yeah so you did shows and then you
went to a tree house yeah and why
seems like you would do that during the
day tree house at night yeah it was
really scary
was it just you and him uh and two of
his other man friends oh man friends
there you go so there you go why are
they recalling all those
Korean cars could you tell us what the
problem
manufacturing error you know we probably
made them quickly to make a lot of money
and then we have to call them back no
don't blow me off what the [__] is the
problem the Koreans and their [__]
cars
there's another pandemic in there we had
to take it back so we don't want it to
release classic Asian walk around
walk around spell W okay
Hans we love you every single week you
come out guns ablazing getting the show
started make some fun look at that gift
I got some kimchi
it's a go box again if you don't pay
attention you're missing out Brian
Holtzman famously brings gifts for
everybody he has them in a bag I'm
guessing he brought that one
specifically for Hans
ah all right ladies and gentlemen